autre exemple où l'europe a permis de
développer un marché régional c'est
celui de gemplus qui fabrique les cartes
à puce valérie chine
jean-claude dépeignant j'aime plus n'a
pas de complexe depuis 1988 l'entreprise
à une croissance de 50 % par an elle
attaque les concurrents poids lourds sur
leur terrain au culot au siège de
gémenos le personnel à 31 en moyenne
parle en tout 15 langues 10 % de ces
jeunes loups sont étrangers le directeur
des ventes
et quitte à lire j'aime plus souvent 3
millions de cartes à puces par mois en
europe avec des bureaux de vente en
grande bretagne italie espagne et
maintenant en allemagne une unité de
production démarre à stuttgart il ya
quinze ans les seuls vrais européens
c'était les gens qui travaillaient pour
des sociétés américaines parce que à
l'époque déjà ou penser europe
on pensait marché global on penser
stratégie globale est en fait lorsque je
suis rentré en france et je suis rentré
pour la première fois dans une grande
société française et que j'ai vu qu'il y
avait un département france est un
département export
en fait j'ai été un petit peu le choc
est déboussolé par cette attitude parce
que effectivement ça paraît pas
correspondre aux réalités de ce qu'est
l'économie européenne est ce que le
marché européen pour l'équipe de
direction l'implantation européenne est
un bon calcul stratégique pour
s'attaquer au marché mondial
amérique asie au niveau de bruxelles ont
mené aussi une activité important un peu
de partenariat nous avons nous
fabriquions aujourd'hui un produit qui
s'appelle une carte à puce que l'on
retrouve dans de très nombreuses
applications média cette carte est
obligé de mettre en place un réseau
mobile et met en place des terminaux que
nous fabriquons pas et que nous
commercialisons en partenariat avec nos
cartes et ses partenariats aujourd'hui
ce nouveau en partie au niveau de
l'europe et de voxels
en europe de l'est la monétique n'est
pas une priorité alors en attendant
sondeurs j'aime plus multiplie les
missions sur place dans les hautes-alpes
une commune endettés ppte